بناء العربيه
واثارت في نفوس ملايين العرب القلق الشديد
على الحاضر والمستقبل لقد تاكد لكل ذي
بصيره ان الحفاظ على الدوله الوطنيه ودعم
مؤسساتها فرض عين وضروره حياه لمستقبل
الشعوب ومقدراتها فلا يستقيم ابدا ان تظل
امال شعوبنا
رهينه للفوضى والتدخلات الخارجيه التي
تفاقم من الاضطرابات وتصيب جهود التسويه
الازمات بالجود
ان الاعتماد على جهودنا المشتركه وقدراتنا
الذاتيه والتكون فيما بيننا لصياغه حلول
حاسمه لقضايانا اصبح واجبا ومسؤوليه كما
ان التطبيق مفهوم العمل العربي المشترك
يتعين ان يمتد ايضا للتعامل مع الازمات
العالميه وتنسيق عملنا العالميه وفي القلب
منها مؤسسات التمويل وبنوك التنميه
الدوليه التي ينبغي ان تكون اكثر استجابه
لتحديات العالم النامي اخزن في الاعتبار
ان حاله الاستقطاب الدولي اصبحت تهدد
منظومه العولمه التي كان العالم يحتفي بها
وتستدعي للواجهه صراعا لفرد الايرادات
وتكريس المعايير المزدوجه في تطبيق
القانون الدولي اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسموم لقد تابعنا بالحزن والالم تصعب
حده بعض الازمات العربيه خلال الفتره
الماضيه لا سيما ما ينتج عن اعمال التصعيد
غير المسؤوله من قبل اسرائيل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
قطاع غزه وبينما تؤكد مصر استمرار جهودها
لتثبيت التهدئه الا اننا نحذر من ان
استمرار اداره الصراع عسكريا وامنيا سيؤدي
الى عواقب وخيمه على الشعبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي على حد سواء ولعله من الملائم
ان نعيد اليوم تاكيد تمسكنا بالخيار
الاستراتيجي بتحقيق السلام الشامل والعادل
من خلال مبادره السلام العربيه وعلى اساس
قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومطالبه اسرائيل
بناء الاحتلال واقامه دوله الفلسطينيه على
حدود الرابع من يونيو
1967 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
واشتغلت كذلك ازمه جديده في السودان
الشقيق تنذر اذا لم نتعاون في احتوائها
بصراع طويل وتبعات كارثيه على السودان
والمنطقه كما تستمر الازمات في ليبيا
واليمن بينما بما يفرض تفعيل التحرك
العربي المشترك لتسويه تلك القضاء على نحو
اكثر الحاحا من اي وقت مضى
وفي نفس السياق فان عوده سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه تعد بمثابه التفعيل العملي
للدور العربي وبدء مسيره عربيه لتسويه
الازمه السوريه استنادا الى مرجعات
الدوليه للحل وقرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسنوب مع
ادراكنا ان الامن القومي العربيه هو كل لا
يتجزا فقد حان الوقت لاخذ زمام المبادره
للحفاظ عليه مما في ذلك من خلال الخطوات
المهمه التي بدرت بها دولنا في الفتره
الماضيه لضبط العلاقات مع الاطراف
الاقليميه غير العربيه التي نتطلع منها
لخضاه مماثله وصادقه بما يسهم في تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه ختاما واكد
ان مصر بما يتموه عنها على الدوام ستدعم
بكل صدق والاخلاص جميع الجهود الحقيقيه
لتفعيل الدور العربي ايمانا منها بان
المقاربات العربيه المشتركه هي الوسيله
المسلى لمراعاه مصالحنا وتوفير الحمايه
الجماعيه لشعبنا ودفع مسيره التنميه خطوات
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي وسبقته
كلمه ملك